hey hey hey hey
i missed you guys man
when i first came in i was just thinking
about this day like you know the day
when i walk out
how you feel right now bro i'm nervous
it's the first show with the car
it was delayed a year because well you
know what happened was
seeing makes it like a prophet if it
wasn't for that man i probably lost my
mind he never shy away from the truth
he human he's like
he's been the same dude his whole life
and that's why it's hard for him to
change because he is the same dude i
wasn't eating three meals a day
i didn't have clothes freely given to me
and i came here to give him a message
the gospel according to x
[Music]
you know what you're getting no
you're getting roughly half the money
okay
can you take the microphone out please
if we know we going to these different
cities i don't know why it's not already
taking care of all these people stealing
it oh no like some big ass judgments and
man no i'm not here to sign
anything
can i get this can i get this give me a
shirt you don't try to disconnect from
everybody because you're stressing about
a lot of different things
do you really love me or
you just want to get something from me
my goal is to
be an inspiration to someone that i
don't know
i'm talking to you from a person who
grew up right where you grew up at i
stole a car from right there
you got to turn that pain into words
you might not know or think that you're
special to god because you've been
through difficult situations
but i'm here to tell you that's why
you're special to god
[Applause]
you